es geht um johnny depp er verklagt die
britische boulevardzeitung sun und in
diesem prozess kommen immer weitere
details aus der ehe mit amber heard raus
der prozess zwischen johnny depp und der
britischen tageszeitung des landes
angesetzt bis zum 27 7
und wohl johnny depp eigentlich schon
ausgesagt hat erscheint er weiterhin vor
gericht und man rechnet auch damit dass
er bis ende des monats bleibt und dafür
dass ich eines der besten hotels der
stadt ausgesucht und zwar das fünf
sterne hotel carinzia das direkt an der
themse gelegen ist und auch der big ben
das nicht weit entfernt aber auch das
hotel von ex frau im bad ist nur 20
gehminuten entfernt in diesem hotel soll
sich johnny depp eine hotel suite
gebucht haben das gebäude ist wirklich
sehr schick eingerichtet am anfang wenn
man reinkommt steht ein tisch voller
ideen hohe decken marmorboden dicke
gepolsterte sessel gut gekleidete
menschen man würde johnny depp
vielleicht nicht sofort hier vororten
sondern eher in einer pendlerin schroffe
hingegen aber es ist wirklich ein sehr
schönes hotel bei dem man auch darauf
achtet diesen besonderen gast zu
schützen und wirklich kein wort über
johnny depp verliert und dieses hotel
ist es auch in dem johnny depp sophie
herrmann kennengelernt haben soll das
ist die stieftochter von uschi glas und
die beiden sollen sich etwas besser
verstehen und hier soll er ihr seine
nummer zugesteckt haben sophie herrmann
ist hier in england ein bekannter
reality-star und spielt in einer sehr
bekannten serie made in chelsea mit und
wer weiß vielleicht haben sie sich hier
auch noch mal getroffen
auf jeden fall weiß man nicht ganz wie
lange johnny depp ihr bleibt aber es ist
damit zu rechnen dass er bis ende juli
hier in diesem hotel schlafen wird und
mir jetzt live aus london zugeschaltet
ist bild reporterin anica anica du hast
dich auch gestern schon für uns im hotel
umgeschaut guten morgen guten morgen
welchen eindruck macht den johnny depp
auf dich hier hat johnny depp macht
einen eindruck auf ein mit dem man nicht
gerechnet hätte er war er kam mir heute
gestern morgen an war top gekleidet hat
eine weste unter seinem anzug hatte
diese allesamt zumindest frisch
gewaschen aus die haut gepflegte bad
getrimmt also eher einen sehr gepflegten
eindruck gemacht war sehr entspannt hat
sich sehr viel zeit genommen
er geht hinter mir hier hält immer dass
der silberne transporter und aktiv den
weg zur treppe immer sehr langsam hoch
begrüßt alle fans winkt den fotografen
zu und es hat eigentlich eher so den
anschein als wäre auf seiner neuesten
premiere eines kinofilms also er macht
einen sehr soliden und ruhigen eindruck
ist relativ gut gelaunt zumindest bisher
das gebäude betritt und zieht sich aber
danach wenn er dann abends nach hause
kommt wohl immer auf sein hotelzimmer
zurück von dem wir eben gerade gehört
haben und das ist auch gar nicht mal so
günstig also das hotelzimmer kostet um
die 2200 euro pro nacht ein kleines glas
whisky das ist auch sein
lieblingsgetränk kostet so um die 30
euro und auch ein sandwich kostet 30
euro aber dafür ist mit inbegriffen ein
persönlicher butler und ein fahrservice
das heißt es ist hier wirklich wirklich
ein luxuszimmer für johnny depp und
kommen wir zurück zum prozess was
erwartet man da heute wer sagt dort
heute aus ja heute morgen wird ben king
aussagen das ist johnny depps haus
manager gewesen in australien und london
während seiner dreharbeiten zu fluch der
karibik und das war eben auch der mann
der johnny depps abgetrennte fingerkuppe
damals gefunden hat nach einem streit
mit amber heard lag die im barbereich
von johnny depps haus herum
im hintergrund war ein zerbrochener
spiegel
so lagen zerbrochene flaschen herum und
der soll halt eben über diesen streit
aussagen hat damals wohl auch amber
heard
von diesem ort entfernt genauso aber
auch winona ryder das ist johnny depp
sechs freunde mit der von 1989 bis 1990
zusammen war
die hat schon vorher gesagt dass er nie
handgreiflich geworden ist ihr gegenüber
und man rechnet damit dass sie eben das
heute auch aus sagt das heißt es könnte
ihm sehr gut in die karten spielen heute
der prozess tag weil auch amber heard ex
assistentin aussagen wird das escape
james die auch sagt sie hat nie
verletzung an ihr gesehen also es
könnten guter siebter prozesstag für
johnny depp werden
dankeschön annika rasch aus london